What's also worse than we could've ever imagined
is the degree to which Donald Trump and people
around him are desperate to endanger the life,
really the lives not only of the Ukraine whistleblower,
but of the whistleblowers family as well.
Now, I told you at the start of the Ukraine
whistleblower fiasco that Donald Trump and
his acolytes will not stop until the whistleblower
is in danger and it actually is starting to
seem like they will not stop until the whistleblower
potentially loses their life.
Trump has already referred to the whistleblower
as a spy, as a trader.
We know that Trump is working very, very hard
to leak the name of the whistleblower despite
whistleblower protection being a core tenant
of the United States.
Trump did one of his magazine safe space rallies
last night in Lexington, Kentucky, Lexington,
Kentucky, rather the home state of totally
toxic ophthalmologist, Senator Rand Paul and
ran Paul and advocate for privacy and advocate
for the rule of law and advocate for the constitution.
Ran Paul claiming that they have the whistleblowers
name and the crowd goes wild and imploring,
imploring the media to out the whistle blower,
printing their name.
They're not going to stop until the whistle
blower maybe dead.
Take a look.
President Trump has great courage.
He faces down the fake media every day.
[inaudible]
but Congress needs to step up and have equal
courage to defend the president.
[inaudible]
Hunter Biden made $50,000 a month.
That's the definition of corruption.
We know we got it only because of his family
connections.
We also now know the name of the whistleblower.
The whistleblower needs to come before Congress
as a material witness because he worked for
Joe Biden at the same time.
Hunter Biden was getting money from corrupt
oligarchy.
I say tonight to the media, do your job and
print his name.
[inaudible]
the crowd.
Cheers that they know the name of the whistleblower.
They want him outed, which will of course
immediately in danger, not only the life of
the whistleblower but of their family as well.
This is the type of thing that Trump Brown
knows.
There is like Ron Paul do when they're on
good terms with Trump, but then sometimes
those relationships with Donald Trump go bad
and Trump abandons them.
They have a falling out and later they'll
say, yeah, maybe that was a mistake.
I don't stand behind everything I did in support
of Trump and when it comes to Ron Paul, it's
particularly hypocritical because Ron Paul
again has been touting his entire political
career.
He is all about the constitution.
He's all about the framework that was established
in the United States of America around privacy
rights.
This has been his entire career and here is
ran Paul privacy advocate, Rand Paul, rule
of law advocate ran Paul talking about let's
violate the framework upon which our country
is based in violation of the whistleblower's
privacy rights for his political gain to ingratiate
himself with Donald Trump, who he's been golfing
with regularly.
Another touch.
By the way, I don't know if if you were listening,
you didn't see this.
If you watched the clip we just played, they
gave the Trumpists standing on the stage behind
Trump tee shirts that say, read the transcript,
which is Trump's continued reference to the
idea that if you just look at the transcript,
it completely vindicates Donald Trump of any
wrongdoing.
Now, of course, they didn't release a transcript
of the phone call.
They released what seemed to be about seven
or eight minutes of conversation from a phone
call that we know lasted a half hour, which
is by the way, extraordinarily incriminating
of Trump.
Trump is not a cognitively strong enough to
recognize that the trans quote transcript,
even the small pieces of it that were published
does not vindicate Trump.
It's incriminating, but they gave everybody
on stage and shirts that say, release the,
read the transcript.
Now what they are asking for here in terms
of media, go ahead and out the whistleblower.
This runs counter to the law.
Now you can feel that politically the whistleblower
should be out at you.
You might take that position as a political
position, but the whistleblower is protected
by law and Donald Trump and ran Paul claim
to be about law and order and law and order
says that the whistle blowers identity must
be protected.
So they're all jumping on this messaging here.
Has Donald Trump two days ago saying the same
thing, expose the whistleblower, which any
reasonable person interprets as instantly
endangering the life of the whistleblower?
Well, the whistleblower gave a very inaccurate
report and as you know, certain of the media,
uh, released information about a man that
they said was the whistle blower.
I don't know if that's true or not, but what
they said is he's an Obama person.
Uh, it was involved with Brennan Susan Rice,
which means Obama.
Uh, he was, but he was like a big, a big,
uh, anti Trump person hated Trump.
Uh, and they, they said terrible things.
Now, I don't know if it's true or not, but
that was recorded by some of the media.
So you'll have to find out.
I don't know why the media is not on it because
the whistle blower gave a very inaccurate
report about my phone call.
My phone call was perfect though it was totally
appropriate, but he gave a report.
He or she, but according to the newspapers,
it's the heat.
They think they know.
They know who it is, you know who it is.
You just don't want to report it.
CNN does do what it is, but you don't want
to report it the way and you know you'd be
doing the public service.
If you did.
The whistle blower gave a false report and
because of that false report, people thought
bad things were done and then you had chip
go out and speak before Congress and before
the American people and give a false, he made
up a story and then I released afterwards.
After all this was done, I relate and everybody
said he didn't do anything wrong, but the
whistle blower should be revealed.
This is an incitement of violence against
the whistleblower.
I mean, listen, you can say Trump is not personally
saying attack the whistleblower, but it is
in practice and incitement of violence against
the whistleblower because they're being exposed
immediately endangers their life.
It's also increasingly irrelevant though.
Okay, and let me explain this to you.
Um, we have Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman.
We have, according to the spectator, which
I talked about earlier today, seven new whistleblowers.
We have Donald Trump's partial transcript
itself, which is massively incriminating.
So the initial whistleblower becomes less
and less relevant every time that their claims
are corroborated.
Think about when someone calls the police
and reports of burglary or a crime of some
kind and they want anonymity, but the police
show up and they investigate and they find
other witnesses that saw the same thing.
They find evidence that corroborates that
initial anonymous report.
It no longer matters who originally made that
first anonymous report.
The whistle blower that Donald Trump wants
outed is increasingly irrelevant as we have
witnesses who were in the room who heard the
July 25 phone call between Trump and Ukrainian
presidents.
Olenski we have Lieutenant Colonel Alexander
Veneman.
So Trump is doing what he does best.
It's really the only thing he can do, which
is deflect the blame, try to distract the
media, make the story an adjudication of the
initial whistleblower and you know that this
is not going well.
Because whenever you hear others come to Trump's
defense, like Ron Paul, in this case, they
don't defend Trump's actions because Trump's
actions are not defensible.
They attack the whistleblower, they go to
the media, and there's another important element
here that we have to consider by doing this.
They are also intimidating future potential
whistleblowers, and I've said this before,
when you make a big show of publicly calling
for the outing of a whistleblower, you are
sending a message to others who know things
that says if you come forward, we will publicly
on the national stage try to out you and your
life will be at risk and the life of your
family will be at risk.
It's sick, it's anti-American, and we can't
allow them to get away with it.
We really can't.
I believe that the fastest recourse of it,
we're, we're a year from the election.
It's just 12 months and then we can end this
national nightmare of what will have been
a four year nightmare.
I believe that that is still the fastest path.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram for more of this story and
others at David Pakman show.
Give us a follow and while you're there, follow
me on instagram@daviddothackmana